- Welcome back to "Understanding Quantum
Information and Computation." My name is John Watrous, and I'm the Technical Director
for IBM Quantum Education.
This is the fifth lesson of the series, and it's the first lesson in
the second unit of the series, which is on Quantum Algorithms.
In this unit, we'll investigate
computational advantages of quantum information, that is, we'll take a
look at what we can do
with quantum computers and the advantages that quantum computers might potentially have
over classical computers.
We're gonna be focusing on what we can do with a single quantum computer as opposed to a distributed
setting, for instance,
where multiple quantum computers interact over a network of some sort.
There are, in fact, quantum advantages to be found in distributed settings, where communication and
cryptography come into play,
but we're not going to be
talking about those things in this unit.
This unit is about quantum algorithms running on single quantum computers.
Let's start with a natural question. What advantages might a quantum
computer potentially offer?
The main one is that quantum computers might provide faster solutions to some computational problems.
Time is precious, and although the computers we
use every day are pretty fast, they're still way too slow
to solve certain computational problems just because of the inherent
computational difficulty of those problems.
This potential that quantum computers might allow us to solve problems that classical computers
are too slow to solve
is really what's driven
quantum algorithms research for the past few decades.
There are other computational
resources besides time that can be considered, like the amount of computer memory required for computations,
but quantum computers can't
offer too much savings in terms of memory, as it turns out, and classical computer
memory is pretty inexpensive
particularly compared with quantum memory. So there just isn't
very much promise here.
We could also think about other resources like the amount of energy
needed for computation, but you don't actually
need much energy at all
to compute classically, particularly if you're
willing to slow things down.
So it really is the time
required for computations, that's our main focus.
Here's an overview for the lesson, which is about a specific
model of computation known as the query model.
You can think of this model as being kind of like a Petri dish for developing algorithmic ideas, both quantum and classical.
It's not meant to be a practical model that describes the sorts
of computational problems we encounter in real life.
We'll move away from the query model in subsequent lessons of this unit and focus instead on models motivated by more practical
notions of computation,
but the query model is a
very good place to start.
It's a simple model that allows us to explore the
potential of quantum computers without a lot of technical
details getting in the way,
and it also allows us to isolate some of the
really important ideas behind quantum computing and how it works.
Quantum computing did, in fact, first develop within this model, and the ideas that were
developed within it very directly inspired
important quantum algorithms
such as Shor's algorithm for factoring.
In the first section of the lesson, we'll take a look at specifically what the query model of computation is,
and in the second, third,
and fourth sections, we'll discuss three
quantum query algorithms, namely Deutsch's algorithm,
the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm,
and Simon's algorithm, which reveal increasingly
impressive advantages
of quantum computers
over classical computers within the query model of computation.
To explain the query model of computation, let's first begin with a more standard
abstraction of computation.
Here's a picture that
represents a computation in very simple and basic terms.
We have an input, which usually takes the
form of a binary string, although we could use other
symbols if we wanted to.
The input is provided to the computation, which is represented by a blue
rectangle in this picture,
and the result of the computation is that some output is produced, and again, that's most
typically a binary string.
Of course, this picture
is not at all specific about how the computation itself works.
We can formulate different
specific computational models to do that, such as Turing machines
and Boolean circuit,
or quantum circuits if we're thinking about
quantum computation.
It's true that this picture
doesn't represent the fact that many of the
computers we use every day are continuously receiving
input and producing output,
essentially interacting with us and with other computers through
the internet, for instance.
But we're not trying to represent
those interactions here.
This is about modeling
isolated computational tasks.
For example, the input might be the
binary encoding of a number or a representation of a matrix
or a description of a molecule or really anything else we have in mind, and there's some computational task
being performed on that input alone.
The key point here is
that the entire input is provided to the computation, and nothing about the
input is hidden from it.
The query model of
computation works differently.
In the query model, the input is made available
in the form of a function which the computation can
access by making queries,
or in other words, by evaluating the function
on different inputs.
Here you can see that represented
in the form of a picture.
Similar to what we had before, the computation is represented
by a blue rectangle, but instead of receiving an input directly
in the form of a string
of bits, for instance, it accesses the input by effectively asking questions
and receiving answers.
We sometimes use the
terms oracle and black box to refer to the mechanism
that provides the input.
There is a distinction between
an oracle and a black box in complexity theory, but that won't be relevant at all for the purposes of this discussion.
Anyway, these terms are meant
to convey the basic idea.
In ancient Greece, you
could go to an oracle, like the Oracle at Delphi,
and ask an important question,
and the oracle would answer
that specific question, but she certainly wouldn't tell you everything that she knew.
Along similar lines, when
we think about a black box, we have in mind some
sort of process or system
where we can choose what goes in and we can see what comes out, but we don't have any understanding
of its inner workings.
And that's the case here. The input to the problem
takes the form of a function, and all that we can do is
to evaluate that function,
but otherwise, we don't have
any knowledge or understanding of how it works.
Throughout the lesson,
we'll reserve the letter f for the function that
represents the input, and we'll make the assumption
that it always takes the
form that you see right here.
Sigma denotes the binary alphabet, so f is a function from strings
of bits to strings of bits,
and specifically, we'll
assume that the input to f is a string of bits having length n, and the output is a string
of bits having length m,
where n and m are positive integers.
For different problems, we'll
have restrictions on n and m, but in all cases, the input function will
take a form like this.
When we say that a
computation makes a query, what we mean is that the
function f is evaluated once,
that is, some string x of length N is selected by the computation, and the string f of x is
then made available to it
by the oracle or the black box. And finally, the very simple way that we'll measure the computational cost
of a query algorithm is to count how many queries it requires.
So, although it is true that
we are really most interested in how long computations take, when we study the query model,
we generally keep things
simple and just count queries, and that's what we will do in this lesson.
Now, let's take a look at a
few examples of query problems, meaning computational
problems in the query model,
and here, by the way, I'm just gonna describe
the problems themselves, and at this point, I won't say anything
about how to solve them.
The first problem is the OR problem.
In this case, the input is a function
from n bits to just 1 bit, so m is equal to 1 for this problem,
and the required output for
the problem is either 1 or 0.
If there is some n bits string x for which f of x is equal to 1, then the correct answer is 1,
and otherwise, if f of x is
always 0 for every string x, then the correct answer is 0.
So if we think about the function f as providing us with random
access to two to the n bits, one for each n bit string x,
then what the it's asking
for is the OR of those bits, and that's why it's called the OR problem.
Another example is the parity problem, which is similar to the OR problem except that asks for the parity,
or in other words, the eXclusive OR of all of the single-bit
output values of the function.
Another way to say that is
that the correct answer is 0 if the number of n bits strings x for which f of x is equal to 1 is even,
and the correct answer is
1 if that number is odd.
An example of a problem where m is not necessarily equal to 1 is the minimum problem.
Here, the function f takes the usual form, and there are no restrictions on n and m,
and the correct answer is whatever output value
of the function comes first in the lexicographic
or dictionary ordering
of binary strings. Alternatively, if you wanna
think about strings of length m as representing non-negative
integers in binary notation,
then the correct answer
is the smallest possible or minimum value that
comes out of this function.
Sometimes we also consider query problems where we have a promise
on the input function, or in other words, some
sort of guarantee on it,
and we don't worry about functions that don't meet that promise.
Functions that don't satisfy the promise are considered as "don't care" inputs.
And we're just not responsible for what happens on those inputs.
Here's an example of a query problem with a promise called unique search.
It's related to the OR
problem, but it's different.
The input function has the same
form as for the OR problem, which is that it takes
n bits strings to bits.
This time, we're promised that
there's exactly one string Z that causes f to evaluate to 1,
with f of x being equal to 0
for every string x besides z, and the correct output
is this unique string z.
Of course, there are
choices for the function f that don't satisfy this condition, but we don't place any requirements at all
on algorithms for this problem when they're given such
functions as input.
We only care about the functions that do satisfy the promise.
Now, all four of the
problems I just mentioned are pretty natural problems, meaning that it's easy to explain them,
and it's easy to imagine situations in which a need to solve them might arise, but some query problems
aren't like this at all.
In fact, sometimes, we consider highly
contrived query problems, where it's difficult to imagine that anyone would ever
actually wanna solve them.
Simon's problem, which we'll
see later in the lesson, kind of falls into this category, but there are some other ones
that are much worse in some sense, but they, nevertheless, actually turn out to be pretty important to the study of the query model.
We don't study these problems because we necessarily want
to solve them in practice.
The way you can think about it is that we are looking for
extremes of various sorts,
in particular, when we're working within
this Petri dish of a model, a natural way to explore
quantum algorithmic ideas
is to formulate highly-contrived problems, where we can best exploit the
power of quantum computers.
And this can actually
shed a great deal of light on how quantum computers
can potentially be useful in more practical settings.
We can formalize the notion
of a query in different ways depending on what computational
model we're working with.
For example, in the Turing
machine model of computation, which we haven't talked about and we won't get into in this series,
there's a certain way of
formalizing the notion of a query that makes sense for that model.
For circuit models, we define special types of
gates called query gates, and that's how queries
are formally represented.
For Boolean circuits, there's a very simple way of doing this, which is simply to imagine
that we have query gates
that evaluate the input function directly, like you can see here on the screen.
The idea is that we can
use these query gates to build circuits that solve whatever
problem we're looking at,
and in order to work correctly, the circuits have to give the right answer for whatever input function f is given,
assuming that it meets the promise in the case of a promise problem.
Here's a simple example
of a Boolean circuit that solves the parity
problem when n is equal to 1,
so the input function f is from
1 bit to 1 bit in this case.
What this circuit does is to evaluate the function
f on the inputs 0 and 1 using these two query gates.
It then plugs the two output values it
gets from the query gates into the Boolean circuit from lesson three that computes the XOR,
which is the same thing as the parity.
To be clear, these two
input values right here are not inputs into the problem,
meaning the parity problem,
when we're working with the query model, the input to the problem
is the function f, and you should think about these
two inputs into the circuit
as being hard-coded
values that never change, they're essentially part of the algorithm.
We want to compute the XOR of f 0 and f 1, so we initialized these
two wires in this way
to make it work. We've used two query gates
here, this one and this one,
and so the algorithm represented
by this Boolean circuit makes two queries, and if we think about the
parity problem for a moment
for functions from one bit to one bit, we see that it's absolutely necessary for any Boolean circuit
that solves this problem
to make at least two queries.
If you only make one query so that you only know one
output value of the function f and not the other, you don't actually have
any information at all
about the parity, because the other output value
could equally well be 0 or 1, leading to either of the
two possible solutions
to the problem. So in terms of the number
of queries that it makes, this Boolean circuit is as good as it gets
for the parity problem
when n is equal to 1.
There's one other point about query gates that's worth mentioning before we move on, and that is that when we're designing and analyzing query algorithms,
we don't worry at all about how
query gates are implemented.
It's assumed that these
query gates are given to us, and the difficulty of building
them isn't our concern.
You can think of the
query gates themselves as being the input if you like, and it's not our job to create the input, we're just trying to
solve a particular problem
given the input. Of course, when f is a function
from one bit to one bit, there are only four possible choices,
and it would be easy enough
to implement any one of them, but in general, for functions
with many input bits,
it could be extremely difficult to implement query gates
for those functions.
To be clear, this isn't
to say that the issue of how query gates are
implemented isn't important, but rather that it isn't considered
to be part of the cost
of a query algorithm.
This is consistent with the idea that this isn't really
about practical computing or actually building circuits per se,
it's about working within
a theoretical framework that tells us interesting
things about computation.
We will have more to say about this when we make the jump from this model to a more standard model of computation, and that's mainly what the next lesson,
Lesson 6, will be about.
Now let's turn our attention
to quantum circuits.
For quantum circuits, we're going to change the
definition of query gates to make them unitary.
We want to be able to make
queries within quantum circuits and for them to operate
linearly on quantum states
so that we can effectively
make queries in super position.
It might seem like we're moving
the goalposts, so to speak, by changing what we mean by a query in comparison to what we just
saw for Boolean circuits,
but there is justification for it that we'll discuss in more
detail in the next lesson.
For now, it's just a definition.
Specifically, the
definition is as follows, given any function f of
the same form as before,
meaning that it maps n bits
strings to m bits strings, the query gate Uf acts on n + m qubits
and is defined by the
action described here on standard basis states.
We'll see a figure
representing this definition in just a moment, but first, let me make clear the notation
that's being used here,
and that is whenever we
use the symbol for the XOR as an operation between two
strings of the same length,
we're referring to the
bitwise eXclusive OR, and here you can see an example.
In the definition, we have that both y and f of
x are strings of length m, so this string right here
represents the string we get
by XORing those two strings
together, one bit at a time, and here's the diagram
explaining how these gates work.
The top n qubits correspond to
the argument of the function.
And when they start out
in a standard basis state, cat x in this diagram, that standard basis state
goes through unchanged
and gets echoed as part of the output.
The bottom m qubits correspond to the output
of the function f, and when they start out in
any standard basis state,
cat y in this diagram, what happens is that the
output of the function f of x gets XORed onto the string y.
This is what happens for
standard basis states, and if we wanna know
what happens in general for other quantum states, we
use linearity, as we always do.
A reason to define query gates like this where we echo the input and we use the bitwise XOR for the output
is that these gates are always unitary for any choice of the function f.
This is, in fact, a
deterministic operation.
And if we were to express it as a matrix for any choice of a function F, we'd get a permutation matrix,
meaning one with a single one in each row and in each column, and all other entries equal to 0.
And permutation matrices
are always unitary.
In fact, for this operation, we'll get that the operation
is its own inverse, so Uf dager equals Uf.
If all we wanna do with these
gates is to evaluate f of x for some string x, that's easy,
we can just set y to
be the all-zero string. So when we take the bit y's eXclusive OR, we end up with just f of x.
Here, by the way, you can see the notation that's used to denote the all-zero string.
It looks like 0 to the power M, but that's not what it means.
It means the string of zeros
having length equal to M.
When we're talking about
strings as opposed to numbers, exponents typically mean that we repeat that string
some number of times,
so this is 0 repeated m times.
It's just a convenient and precise way of describing this string.
Once again, when we're
working with the query model, we aren't worrying about how
to implement these query gates.
That's the same issue
we had with query gates for Boolean circuit.
It's not our job to prepare the input, we're given the input in the
form of these query gates.
I will point out though, that if we know how to
implement the function f using a Boolean circuit, then it is possible to
translate that implementation
pretty directly to a quantum
circuit implementation of Uf, and we'll see exactly how
that works in the next lesson.
As an aside, it is quite straightforward to create a Boolean circuit
that operates like this, using a single classical
query gate for the function f,
but that is quite different from having a quantum
circuit implementation of this unitary gate.
The point, however, is that
for classical query algorithms, having a query gate that works like this is, in fact, equivalent
to having an ordinary
classical query gate for f, in the sense that either one can be implemented using the other.
In this section of the lesson, we'll discuss Deutsch's algorithm, which is a very simple
quantum query algorithm, but it really is a gem.
This algorithm comes from a 1985 paper written by David Deutsch, was one of the very first people to work on the theoretical
foundations of quantum computing.
The algorithm itself represents a very small part
of Deutsch's 1985 paper, and in fact,
the algorithm we now
call Deutsch's algorithm is actually an improved version of the algorithm that Deutsch described.
It provides a very modest example of how quantum computers can
offer computational advantages, but you have to start somewhere,
and it really was an important spark that got things started.
Deutsch's algorithm solves a query problem that's often called Deutsch's problem in the context of quantum computing,
but in fact, it's none other
than the parity problem for functions from one bit to one bit, which we've already talked about.
As we've already seen, there are four functions
from one bit to one bit, and they're described here on the screen by their tables of values.
The first and last of these
functions are constant, while the middle two are balanced in the sense that the two
possible output values
appear the same number of times.
For the two constant functions,
we see that the parity, or in other words, the eXclusive OR of the two outputs is 0,
and for the two balance functions, the parity of the outputs is 1.
So an equivalent way to
describe the parity problem in this particular case, where the function f takes
a single bit as input,
or in other words, Deutsch's problem, is like you see here.
The input is a function f
from one bit to one bit, and the output is 0 if f is constant
and 1 if f is balanced.
As I've already suggested, every classical query algorithm
that solves this problem must make at least two queries to f.
If you learn just one of
the two output values of f, you still have no information at all about the parity of the two outputs.
And this, by the way, is true
even for classical algorithms that make use of randomness.
Randomness can sometimes be very useful for solving query problems, and we'll see an example
a bit later in the lesson,
but randomness doesn't help here.
So our algorithm from before is optimal among classical query algorithms
for Deutsch's problem.
Now we'll take a look
at Deutsche's algorithm, which is a quantum query algorithm that solves Deutsch's
problem using a single query.
And here is the algorithm
described as a quantum circuit.
We have two qubits
initialized like you see here, with the top one initialized to cat 0 and the bottom one initialized to cat 1,
and we'll see why we initialize these qubits like this shortly.
We perform Hadamard
gates on the two qubits, feed them into the query gate, perform another Hadamard
gate on the top qubit,
and then measure it. And the claim is that
the measurement outcome gives us, with certainty, the
correct answer to the problem.
So let's analyze the
circuit one step at a time to see exactly how it works.
The state of the two qubits after the first layer of Hadamard gates is the tensor product of
the minus and plus states.
The Hadamard on top maps
the 0 state to a plus state, and the Hadamard on the bottom maps the 1 state to a minus state.
The top qubit is on the right, and the bottom qubit is on the left, so this is the state that we get.
It's very important that the bottom qubit is in a minus state, by the way, this wouldn't work if we
initialize the bottom qubit
to a 0 state instead of a 1 state.
We're going to expand this state
halfway, like you see here.
The reason for doing that
isn't clear at this point, but it will be convenient
in just a moment.
Next, let's think about
the state of the two qubits after the query gate is performed.
The way the query gate
works is that it computes F on the standard basis
state of the top qubit and XOR is the value
onto the bottom qubit,
and here we can see the
result of doing that.
For the first term, the standard basis state
of the top qubit is 0, so f of zero gets XORed
onto the bottom qubit,
and that works by linearity. And it's similar for the second term, except that the standard basis state
for the top qubit is 1, so we XOR f of 1 onto the bottom qubit.
And at this point, we can
simplify this expression by observing the formula
that you can see down here, which works when a is either 0 or 1.
And we can simply check this for those two values separately.
If a is equal to 0, then
XORing with a does nothing, and negative 1 to the power 0 is 1,
so the two sides are equal. And if a is equal to 1, we get cat 1 minus cat
0 when we take the XOR,
which is negative 1
times cat 0 minus cat 1.
And if we use that formula
to simplify our state, where we take a is equal
to f of 0 on the left and a is equal to f of 1 on the right,
we get the expression
that you see right here.
So when we compare the two
quantum state vectors π1 and π2, we see that what the Uf gate does
is effectively to put
one of the two values, f of 0 or f of 1, into the
exponent of negative 1,
or in other words, into
the phase of each term.
This is the reason for
initializing the bottom qubit to 1 and performing a Hadamard gate on it to create the minus state,
which allows this to happen.
It's called the phase kickback phenomenon, and we'll come back to it in a few moments to have another look at it.
It's pretty important, and we'll see it happening a
few more times in the lesson, as well as in later lessons.
We can now simplify by pulling
the minus state back outside to get the expression
that you see right here.
As an aside, it's kind
of interesting to notice that there isn't actually
any entanglement here.
Both of these states are product states. So, well, entanglement
is extremely interesting,
doesn't happen to be
playing any role at all in this particular algorithm.
Let's clean this up a bit so that we have a little bit more room.
What we can now do is to
pull a factor of negative 1 raised to the power f of zero outside
to get the expression of the
state that you see right here.
You'll notice that right here, we have eXclusive OR of f 0 and f 1 in the exponent of negative 1.
We might expect that to
be f of 1 minus f of 0 because we pull the factor of negative 1 to the power f of 0 out,
but we get the same
value if we take the XOR because these are bits, and the only thing that matters when we have an integer in
the exponent of negative 1
is whether that integer is even or odd.
Another way to express this
state is like we have here, where we're just considering
the two possible cases for the XOR.
and that's a convenient
way to express the state as we consider the action
of the final Hadamard gate together with the measurement.
When we perform the last
Hadamard gate on the top qubit, the plus state is
transformed into a 0 state
and the minus state is
transformed into a 1 state, which we can write more
succinctly like this.
And finally, when the
measurement is performed, the result we obtain is
therefore the XOR of f 0 and f 1,
which is the value we're looking for, and that's how Deutsch's algorithm works.
It's pretty simple, and if we ask ourselves what
it is that makes it work, allowing us to compute
the parity of two bits
with a single query rather than two, a reasonable answer is
that it's interference.
We're effectively
computing f of 0 and f of 1 at the same time, because we first performed
the Hadamard gate
on the top qubit to put the input into f into
a super position of 0 and 1.
And by means of the phase kickback together with the final Hadamard gate, we're essentially creating
constructive interference
for the correct answer and destructive interference
for the wrong answer.
So we don't see the wrong answer, we only see the correct answer.
Let me now say a bit more about the phase kickback phenomenon just to see it from a
slightly different angle.
First, let's observe
this very simple formula where b and c are arbitrary binary values.
In short, XORing a bit b by the value 1 is the same thing as performing a NOT gate or an x operation on b,
and of course, exploring
a bit b by the value 0 doesn't do anything to it, which is the same thing as performing the
identity operation on it.
And we can express the identity operation as x to the power 0.
So if we perform a Uf gate on two qubits in the standard basis
state cat b tensor cat a,
we obtain this outcome, just by the definition of the Uf gate.
and by using the formula, we can alternatively write that state like you see right here.
This formula works for all choices of b, so by linearity, it works
for an arbitrary state SI
in place of cat b.
And in particular, if we want to, we can choose SI to be the minus state.
And now here's the key to why the phase x kickback
phenomenon happens.
It's because the x operation
applied to the minus state gives us negative 1 times the minus state.
In mathematical terms, we say that the minus
state is an eigenvector of the x operation, with eigen value equal to negative 1.
Eigenvectors and eigen values
are critically important in linear algebra as well
as in quantum information, and we'll have a lot
more to say about them
as the series continues.
But for now, all we need
is this simple formula.
And using it, we can
simplify our state vector.
And that right there is essentially the phase
kickback phenomenon written as a formula.
It works because the minus
state is an eigenvector of the NOT operation having
eigen value negative one.
We will generalize this in a
pretty major way in Lesson 7, when we turn to the phase
estimation procedure, which is what drives
Shor's factoring algorithm.
We can see this formula in action in the analysis of Deutsch's
algorithm as follows.
Prior to the query gate, our state is the tensor product of the minus and plus states.
We then apply the query gate, and expanding out the plus
state gives us this state.
We now apply the phase kickback formula to get this expression, and then the analysis
carries on as before.
It's the same as before, but here we're just placing
a focus on the phase kickback so that we can recognize it
and we can also be ready for
it when it comes up again.
Next we'll turn to the
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, which is an extension
of Deutsch's algorithm that actually solves a couple
of different query problems.
The advantage that
Deutsch's algorithm provides over classical algorithms
is pretty modest, one query versus two.
The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm increases that advantage somewhat, and I'll explain what I mean
by that when we get there.
The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm can be viewed as a natural and direct way of extending Deutsch's algorithm
from functions from one bit to one bit to functions from n bits to one bit, or another words, functions of this form.
As a quantum circuit, the Deutsch-Jozsa
algorithm looks like this, and I'm going to refer to this
as the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
just to draw a minor
distinction between this circuit and the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm itself because there's also a
classical post-processing step.
The idea is that if we run
this circuit and then measure, we'll obtain some n bits string y
that tells us something
about the function f.
At this point, by the way, I haven't actually said
what the query problem is that we might hope to
solve with this circuit, that's coming up very soon.
But the point is that
by running this circuit, we'll gain some information about f that can potentially help
us to solve query problems
where f is the input. And like I said a moment ago, we can actually use this circuit
to solve a couple of
different query problems.
First, let's take a look
at the query problem known as the Deutsch-Jozsa problem, which is the problem that
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit
was originally intended to solve.
The Deutsch-Jozsa problem is a generalization of Deutsch's problem, where the goal is to determine whether a given function
is constant or balanced.
Notice that this isn't the natural way to generalize the parity problem
to functions of this form.
Here we're not computing the parity, the task is to output 0 if
the function f is constant
and 1 if the function f is balanced.
The first thing to notice about
this problem is that when n, the number of input bits to
the function f, is at least 2,
there are choices for the function that are neither constant nor balanced.
For example, here's a
function from 2 bits to 1 bit that's neither constant nor balanced.
It's not constant because both binary values
appear among the outputs, and it's not balanced
because the two output values
appear with different frequencies. 0 appears three times
and 1 appears just once.
In order to be balanced,
the outputs 0 and 1 have to occur exactly
the same number of times.
The fact that there are functions that are neither constant nor balanced when n is at least 2 is okay though, we're just gonna consider
functions like that
as "don't care" inputs. So in other words, this
is a promise problem.
And here's a precise
statement of the problem.
We're promised that the input function f is either constant or balanced, and the goal is to figure
out which one it is.
And we're not responsible for what happens if the input
doesn't meet the promise.
The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm,
which solves this problem, is first to run the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit and then output 0
if the string that we
obtain from the measurements is the all-zero string
and output 1 otherwise.
Another way to say that is that we output the OR of
the bits that we measure.
To analyze the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, it'll be helpful to
first take a few moments to think about Hadamard gates.
We can, of course, describe the Hadamard
operation as a matrix, but we can also describe
it in terms of its action
on standard basis states,
as you see right here.
These two equations can be
combined into a single equation, which describes how a
Hadamard operation works for a being either of
the two binary values,
and we can go a little bit further and express what we
obtain as a sum like this.
Using that formula, we can come up with a formula that describes how a layer
of Hadamard gates works, where we apply one Hadamard
gate to each of n qubits.
Here we're describing this
action on standard basis states.
And to be clear about the notation, when we write h tensor n like this, where the tensor n part is a superscript,
what we mean is the n fold
tensor product of H with itself, or in other words, n copies
of h all tensor together.
We're applying this operation
to a standard basis state, and here I'm following the
convention that Qiskit uses
to index binary strings, just because it's a good time
to introduce that convention.
So x0 is a bit, x1 is a bit,
and so on with n bits in total, and the bits are ordered as
you see here on the screen.
You can think about this
way of indexing bits as corresponding to their significance if we view strings as
representing integers
in binary notation, for instance.
If we apply a Hadamard gate
to each of these qubits, we can alternatively express the result as the n fold tensor product
of a Hadamar gate applied to each qubit, and then we can apply our formula to each one of the tensor factors.
And here we're using the
names y and minus 1 down to y1 in place of b in the formula,
so these are binary values. And we're making sure to use a new name each time we use the formula.
If we then expand everything out using the multilinearity
of tensor products, we get the expression
that you see right here.
And to be clear, the n sums are being
combined into a single sum, but we're still summing
over all the possible values
for the individual binary values.
Now let's clean things up so that we can go a little bit further.
And the next step is to
introduce a new operation on strings called the binary dot product.
This is an operation on binary strings having the same length.
And what the binary dot product of two strings x and y
of the same length is, is the eXclusive OR or the parity
of the products of the individual bits.
You could also say that it's the XOR of the logical and of the individual bits, because the and is the
same thing as the product
for binary values. Yet another way to describe
it is that it's 1 or 0
depending on whether
the sum of the products of the individual bits is odd or even.
It's very much like an inner product if we think about strings
as vectors of binary values, but where we compute Modulo-2,
or in other words, we take the remainder after dividing by 2.
It's not really an inner product though, so it deserves a different name.
In the case at hand, we can use the binary dot
product to make our formula for the action of a layer of Hadamard gate
on standard basis states more succinct, and here it is right here.
We're using the fact that
because this sum right here is appearing in the
exponent of negative 1,
all that matters is whether
or not it's even or odd, but otherwise, it's basically just a condensed
version of our formula.
By the way, the binary
dot product is symmetric in the sense that x dot
y and y dot x are equal,
so we are free to swap the
ordering whenever that's useful.
And now that we have that formula, it'll be pretty easy to analyze
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
We start out with n qubits in the 0 state and the bottom qubit in the 1 state, and we perform Hadamard
gates on all of them.
So this is the state of the
n + 1 qubits that we get.
We are treating the
bottom qubit separately because that's gonna be convenient.
And again, we're gonna see the phase
kickback phenomenon happening.
We can get this expression
by using our formula, where we substitute the
all-zero string for x and substitute x for y,
noting that the binary dot
product of the all-zero string with any string is 0.
But we can also just reason this directly. We're taking the tensor
product of n plus states, and this is what we get,
tensor to the minus state. Then the UF gate is applied, and here's where the phase
kickback phenomenon happens.
The value f of x is getting
XORed onto the minus state for each x in the sum.
So f of x gets kicked into the phase.
We now apply another
layer of Hadamard gates just to the top n qubits, and this time, we really
do need the formula.
And when we apply it and do just a little
bit of simplification, we get this state right here.
So that's our final state just
prior to the measurements.
The state looks a little bit complicated, and it's difficult to simplify it because we don't really know
anything about the function f.
But remember, that all
we really need to know is whether or not the measurements
all yield the outcome 0,
because that's what determines what our answer is to the problem.
If we see that every
measurement outcome is 0, we conclude that the function is constant.
And if any one of the
measurement outcomes is 1, we conclude that the function is balanced.
So let's calculate the probability to get the all-zero string
from the measurements.
And that turns out to be the one result that's actually easy to calculate, because the binary dot
product of the all-zero string
with any string is zero. If we examine our vector and
we think about what happens when y is the all-zero string,
we get this expression right
here for the probability to get the all-zero string
from the measurements.
And considering the two possible cases where f is constant and f is balanced, we see that the probability to
get the all-zero string is 1
in the case that f is constant, and zero when f is balanced.
When f is constant, the sum is either 2 to the
n or negative 2 to the n, and dividing by two to the n
and taking the absolute
value squared yields 1.
And when f is balanced, the sum equals 0.
That's because we'll get
positive 1 and negative 1 an equal number of times,
so they all cancel out.
So that's it. The Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm
solves the Deutsch-Jozsa problem using a single query,
and there's no error. Assuming the operations
are all done perfectly, it's correct every single time.
So how does that compare with
what we can do classically?
Well, if we insist on a
deterministic algorithm that gets the answer
correct every single time, then in the worst case,
we need 2 to the n minus 1 plus 1 queries, and that's because we
have to query the function
on more than half of its inputs to be sure about the solution.
Even if we query the function on 2 to the n minus 1
different input strings, it's possible that we'll
see the same output value
every single time, and that could be because
the function is constant, or it could be that it's actually balanced
and we've just been incredibly unlucky having seen the same output
value every single time.
So that's a huge advantage
of quantum over classical, a single query versus
exponentially many queries.
However, if we use a
probabilistic query algorithm and we accept a small probability that it answers incorrectly,
then we actually only need a few queries.
In particular, if we
randomly choose k strings and evaluate the function
on those random strings,
then we are pretty likely to be able to figure out the right answer.
Specifically, we answer 0 or constant when we get the same function
value every single time and 1 or balanced
whenever we see two
different function values.
If we do that, we'll always be correct when
the function is constant because, of course, we'll always see the same
output value in this case.
And if f is balanced, we're very likely to see
two different output values.
The chance that we don't see
both output values in this case is the same as the chance that we have of flipping a coin k times
and getting the same
result every single time.
So for example, if we
set k to be equal to 11, the probability of getting a wrong answer is less than a 10th of a percent.
So especially when we consider the fact that quantum computers are never going to be perfect in reality, we don't actually get that
big of an advantage here,
but we're making progress, and we do have a quantifiable advantage of quantum over classical that goes beyond Deutsch's algorithm.
We can also use the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit to solve a different query problem known as the Bernstein-Vazirani problem.
Here's a statement of that problem. The input is a function
from n bits to 1 bit, just like the Deutsch-Jozsa problem,
and again, it's a promise problem.
This time, the promise is that there exists some n bits string s for which the function f
works as you see right here,
where the output is given
by the binary dot product of the input with this string s,
and the goal is simply
to find the string s. So we can imagine that the
string s is hidden in some sense,
but we can learn about it
by making queries to f, and our goal is to find
this hidden string.
To be clear, most functions
won't satisfy this promise, but as usual, we only care about the
input functions that do.
As it turns out, the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit actually solves this problem
right out of the box.
If we run it for a
function like we have here that satisfies the
promise for some string s, the measurements will reveal the string s
with no post-processing required.
So let's see how this works.
We've already analyzed
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, so we can actually just
skip right to the end.
Here's the expression that we
had from before for the state just prior to the measurements, and that expression was
valid for any function f.
And now, if we substitute
in what we're promised about the function f and simplify,
we get the minus state
for the bottom qubit tensored with cat s for the top n qubits.
And so we get s when we measure.
There is some work to do to perform the simplifications
that I've shown here, and I won't go through that in this video,
but there is more detail about it in the textbook content for this series, which you can find by following the link in the description of the video,
or just try it for
yourself for some practice.
So what we found is that
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit solves the Bernstein-Vazirani
problem with a single query.
It's not too hard to show
that any classical algorithm, whether it's deterministic
or probabilistic, needs at least n queries
to solve the Bernstein-Vazirani problem for the simple reason that we need n bits of
information to recover s,
and each query gives us at
most 1 bit of information.
So we get another advantage of quantum over classical
query algorithms, one query for quantum algorithms,
n queries for classical algorithms.
It's worth taking just a moment to speak about the
nomenclature that's used in the context of this problem and a little bit about the history.
People sometimes refer to the algorithm that I just described as being the Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm, but it's really just the
Deutsch-Jozsa circuit,
and that's something that was,
in fact, very clearly stated in Bernstein and Vazirani's work.
So it is a little bit strange that it's called the
Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm because it's pretty much the same thing as the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm
minus the post-processing. Bernstein and Vazirani did,
however, go a step further.
They defined a recursive
version of this problem, where you basically
have to solve instances of the Bernstein-Vazirani problem
to unlock new instances of the problem that are arranged in a
complicated tree-like pattern.
It's a highly contrived problem, but the point is that by
defining a problem in this way, they could effectively stretch out
the one versus n query separation between quantum and classical.
And what they obtained is
the very first known example of a so-called super polynomial advantage of quantum over probabilistic algorithms.
This recursive version of the
Bernstein-Vazirani problem also turned out much later
to be very interesting in computational complexity
theory for different reasons.
Anyway, the point is that
Bernstein and Vazirani certainly deserve recognition for their important contributions,
but it really doesn't make
sense to refer to this as the Bernstein-Vazirani algorithm, it's basically just the
Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
In the last part of the lesson, we'll take a look at one
more quantum query algorithm known as Simon's algorithm.
You'll see a clear similarity
between this algorithm and the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm, but it is different, and more importantly,
it reveals a much stronger advantage of quantum over classical
query algorithms.
Specifically, it gives us a
provable exponential advantage of quantum over classical algorithms, even probabilistic ones.
The problem it solves is a bit artificial, and it's hard to imagine a situation in which solving this
problem would be useful,
but it did directly inspire
Peter Shor's discovery of a quantum algorithm
for integer factorization,
and that very strongly supports
this idea of the query model as a Petri dish in which quantum algorithmic
ideas can be developed.
Let's start with the query problem that Simon's algorithm solves, which, as you might have guessed,
is called Simon's problem.
Here's a statement of the problem, and we're going to need to unpack it to understand what it's all about.
The first thing to
notice is that this time, the input function f maps n
bits strings to m bits strings
where m is some positive integer that isn't equal to one in general.
It's a promise problem. And like the Bernstein-Vazirani problem, the promise involves some string s that we can view as being a hidden string,
and also like the
Bernstein-Vazirani problem, the goal is to output
this hidden string s.
The promise is more
complicated this time though, so let's take it apart and
understand what it's saying.
To begin, let's just read it. It says that there exists a string s having length equal to n
such that a particular "if"
and "only if" condition is true for all choices of n bits strings x and y.
Specifically, it must
be the case that f of x is equal to f of y if and only if one of
two possibilities holds.
The first possibility is that x equals y, and the second possibility is that by taking the
bitwise eXclusive OR of x
in the hidden string s, we get Y.
This turns out to be a
pretty strict promise in the sense that most
functions won't satisfy it.
Only very special functions
satisfy this condition.
Now, to get a better grasp on this promise and therefore on the problem itself, we'll consider two main cases.
The first case is that s
is the all-zero string.
In this case, we can simplify the "if"
and "only if" statement in the promise because the bitwise
eXclusive OR of any string x
with the all-zero string
is simply the string x.
So the condition simplifies
to f of x is equal to f of y if and only if x equals y.
And that's just another way of saying that f is a one to one function.
In other words, the string f of x must be unique
for each possible string x.
So if f is a one to one function, then the promise is indeed satisfied, specifically for s being
the all-zero string,
and in this case, that's
the correct output.
The second case is that s
is not the all-zero string, and what this implies is that the function f must be two to one.
So for every input string x, there's exactly one other string that f maps to the same
string that x maps to,
and moreover, the other string
must be the string we get by taking the bitwise
eXclusive OR of x with s.
Another way of saying this
is that every n bit string x has a partner, and that partner is the string that we get
by taking the bitwise eXclusive OR with s.
Any two partners must give
us the same output string if we plug them into f, and no other strings are allowed to give us
that same output string.
So these are necessarily distinct strings that partners produce.
Here's an example of a function like this described by its table of values.
So this is a function
from 3 bits to 5 bits.
If we stare at this table
of values for a while, we find that the promise is
satisfied for the string 011.
000 and 011 are partners. XORing either one of them
by s gives us the other,
and they take the same output value, which is 10011 in this particular case, and no other strings produce
that same output string.
001 and 010 are partners because XORing either
one by s gives the other, and they produce the same output value,
which again, isn't produced
by any other string.
And the situation is
similar for 100 and 111 as well as 101 and 110.
So if the input to the
problem is this function, the correct answer is the string 011.
Like I said before, most functions don't satisfy this promise, it's a very specific condition.
It should also be noted that
if the promise is satisfied, it can only be satisfied for one string s.
So there's always only one
correct answer to this problem.
So that is Simon's problem. Like I said, it's hard to imagine a practical situation in which you'd wanna solve this problem,
but that isn't the point. The point is to try to figure out what quantum computers are good at, and it turns out that they're far superior
to classical algorithms for
solving this particular problem.
Now let's take a look
at Simon's algorithm, which solves Simon's problem.
The algorithm consists of
running the quantum circuit that you see here several times, followed by a classical
post-processing step,
and we'll be more specific about what several
times means a bit later.
The circuit looks very similar
to the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit, this time because the function
f maps n bits to m bits,
the query gate is different. Rather than just a single
qubit on the bottom, we now have m qubits on the bottom
and n on the top like before.
A key difference is that we're
not setting up a minus state or multiple minus states on the bottom.
These bottom qubits are all
initialized to the 0 state, and those states go straight
into the query gate.
So there won't be any phase kickback involved in this algorithm, it's just not how this one works.
Other than the differences
I just mentioned though, it looks very similar to
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
We apply a layer of Hadamard gates, then we apply a query gate one time, and then we apply another
layer of Hadamard gates
followed by standard basis measurements of the top n qubits.
The idea is that each time we
run this circuit and measure, we'll get some string y that tells us something
about the hidden string s
in Simon's problem. And by running the circuit
several times independently, we will have gathered enough
statistical evidence about s
to be able to figure out what
it is with high confidence.
Now let's analyze the quantum
circuit for Simon's algorithm to see what it does.
The state after the first
layer of Hadamard gates looks like this, similar to what we had for
the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
Except this time, the bottom m qubits are all in the 0 state
rather than in minus states.
After the query gate is performed, we see that the value f of x has been written onto the
bottom or leftmost m qubits,
and that's because f of x has been XORed onto the all-zero string.
So again, there's no phase kickback happening in this algorithm.
We then perform the second
layer of Hadamard gates.
And using the same formula as before for the action of a
layer of Hadamard gates on a standard basis
state, cat x in this case,
as it was in the original formula, we obtain this state right here, where the action of the Hadamard gates
has been made more apparent. But if we want to, we can also write the state
in a more compact form like we have right here.
At this point, we measure the top n qubits to obtain some end bit string y, and we just need to figure
out what the probabilities are
for the different strings. And that'll help us to understand
what information we get from this string y about the string s
that's hidden inside of the function f.
We're going to need
some more room for this, and we really don't need
the circuit diagram anymore, so let's get rid of it and give ourselves some
more space for the analysis.
Here's the state just
prior to the measurements, which are standard basis measurements of the top or rightmost n qubits.
So the measurement
corresponds to the second cat.
Let's denote by p of y, the probability that the measurements give us the string y for each possible y.
And if we follow the rules from Lesson 2, we get that each of these probabilities is the Euclidean norm squared of whatever vector is tensored
to the standard basis state,
corresponding to why in
our quantum state vector.
That gives us this expression right here.
Now, to get a better handle
on these probabilities, we're gonna need to make
use of some notation, and you might already be
familiar with this notation
because it's pretty common in mathematics.
First, when we refer to the
range of the function f, we just mean the set of all the strings that can come out of this function.
So it's the set of all f of x ranging over all the possible
choices of an input string x.
Second, we're gonna use this notation that you see right here to mean the set of all the input strings x
that f maps to a given string z, for whatever choice of
z we wanna consider.
It kind of looks like the
inverse of the function f, but it's not really the inverse because f is not necessarily invertible.
We also see that we have
a set as the argument on the left hand side, and in this case, it's the set containing
just a single string z,
and that's the clue we need to recognize that we're not talking about
the inverse of the function f, this is called the pre-image.
The pre-image can be
defined more generally for any set given as an argument, not just the set containing
a single element,
but this is all that we're gonna need. It's not the greatest
notation in the world because it's easy to
confuse it with the inverse,
but it's clear enough
and it's widely used, so we're gonna go with it.
And now if we use this notation, we can rewrite the vector that we're taking the
Euclidean norm squared of to get the probability for
measuring each string y.
We're doing this because we need to see
what the coefficients are for each individual standard basis state, and that's not clear from
this expression right here,
because, in general, we may
have multiple choices of x giving us the same string f of x.
In essence, all we're doing
is splitting up the sum over x by first summing overall
z in the range of f,
and then inside of that sum, summing over all x in the pre-image of z, or to be more accurate,
the pre-image of the set
containing the string z.
That lets us replace f of x with z inside of the cat right here.
And the sum overall, the different strings
x that f maps to each z are collected into the
coefficient for each cat.
We're basically putting strings into bins, summing over the bins, and then summing over
the strings in each bin,
but that's equivalent to just
summing over all the strings.
So we do obtain an expression that's equivalent to the
one that we started with,
and now we can compute the
Euclidean norm squared.
It's just the sum of the squares of the absolute values
of the coefficients, and so, we get this expression right here
for our probabilities.
Of course, give yourself
time to verify this, if you choose to do that, it takes time to get used to all this
and to be able to perform
these calculations, and the more practice you give yourself, the easier it'll become.
So far, we haven't actually
made use of the promise in Simon's problem at all.
Our analysis of these probabilities actually works for any function f, but now it's time to think about Simon's
problems specifically.
We're going to break things down into the same two cases
that we had before.
The first case is that s
is the all-zero string, and the second case is that
s is not the all-zero string.
In the first case, that
s is the all-zero string, things are pretty simple.
In this case, as we saw before, we have that f is a one to one function, so there's a single string x
that gets mapped to each of the
strings z in the range of f.
That makes the absolute value squared of the sum over those strings equal to 1 because there's just a
single term in the sum,
it's either plus 1 or minus 1, but it doesn't matter which because we take the
absolute value squared, and so we get one.
There are 2 to the n
elements in the range of f, and we know that because f is one to one, so there's one string in the
range for each input string.
And if we evaluate the entire expression, we find that each string y appears with probability
one over two to the n.
So in other words, the
measurements give us a string y chosen uniformly at random.
That might not seem all that useful, but we will, in fact, be able
to distinguish this behavior from the behavior we get in the case
that s is not the all-zero string, and we'll see how that goes shortly.
For now though, we simply observe that if
f satisfies the promise in Simon's problem in the case that s is the all-zero string,
then the result of the measurements is a uniform random string.
Now let's move on to the second case, which is that the promise
is satisfied for a string s that's not the all zero-string.
In this case, as we discussed before, each string z in the range of f has exactly two strings that map to it,
because every string has a partner, and each pair of partners
maps to some unique string, and specifically, each string's partner
is the string we get by XORing with s.
So if we pick any string
z in the range of f, and we give the name w to either one of the
strings that f maps to z,
then the XOR of w with s is the
other string that maps to z.
Looking at just the one term in our sum that corresponds to whatever string z in the range that we have in mind,
we see that we can
write it more explicitly as we have right here.
We have two strings in the pre-image of z, w and w XORed with s.
So we can write the sum
as you see on the screen, and now what we can do is we can pull out a factor of
negative 1 to the power w.y.
That factor is going to be
either plus 1 or minus 1, so it goes away when we
take the absolute value,
and what we're left with is
this expression right here.
The details aren't all shown here, and it's not necessarily
obvious that it works this way, but you can check that these
two expressions are equal
by going back to the definition
of the binary dot product and thinking about what happens when these things are in
the exponent of negative 1,
not unlike what we had for the
Bernstein-Vazirani problem.
Finally, we can break this
expression up into two cases.
It's 4 when the binary dot
product of s and y is 0, and it's 0 when the binary
dot product of s and y is 1.
Notice in particular that
there's no dependence at all here on w or z, it only depends on s and y.
The reason this happens is
because of the very specific and special nature of the promise.
In essence, this is why the promise was formulated in this way, so it would all work out like this.
Again, every string has a partner, which we get by XORing with
this one hidden string s,
and that's what makes this all happen.
We can now go back to the
expression for the probabilities and plug things in.
When s is not the all-zero string, there are 2 to the n minus 1
elements in the range of f,
which is half of the
number of input strings, and plugging in the
values we just calculated gives this formula right here.
So this time, y is not a
completely random string, but rather y is uniform over exactly half of the n bit strings,
and specifically, it's
uniform over those strings that have binary dot
product equal to 0 with s.
Now that we know how the circuit
for Simon's algorithm works and specifically what
the probabilities are for the different measurement outcomes,
it remains to explain how this helps us to solve Simon's problem.
Summarizing what we just learned, if it's the case that the function f satisfies the promise in Simon's problem,
when the hidden string s
is the all-zero string, we obtain a completely random
string from the measurements,
where each end bit string
y is equally likely.
If on the other hand, the function f satisfies the promise for a different string s, one that's not equal
to the all-zero string,
then we get a random string y having binary dot product
equal to 0 with s, and among all of those strings,
each y is equally likely.
But we'll never get a string y having binary dot product
equal to 1 with s.
The question becomes, "Is this enough information
to determine s?" And the answer, as I've
already suggested, is yes,
provided that we run the
circuit enough times.
Specifically, let's suppose
that we run the circuit k times, where K is equal to n plus r,
where r is some number that's going to control the
likelihood that we recover s.
Just as an example, if
we choose r to be 10, we'll be successful with
probability greater than 99.9%,
so we don't need r to be all that large.
In general, the probability of failure is less than the probability
of flipping a fair coin r times and getting heads every single time.
So if 99.9% isn't good
enough, then take r to be 20, and the chance of failure is
less than one in a million,
or choose whatever r
makes you comfortable. You can't guarantee a correct solution, but you can make the
probability of error negligible
for all intents and purposes.
Here we are naming these
strings y1 through yk, where we're using superscripts to help us to name these strings,
just so that we can reserve subscripts to refer to the individual
bits of those strings.
So these aren't exponents
or anything like that, these are just the names that we're giving to these k strings.
Each one has length n because we got them
from running the circuit for Simon's algorithm.
So we can write down the
individual bits of these k strings like you see right here.
What we do now is to create a matrix m, where each entry of this matrix is a bit, and we get these bits from the strings
that we just measured, just like as shown right here.
So this matrix has k rows and n columns, and its entries are all binary values.
Now, we don't know what s is. That's what we're trying to find, but just imagine for a
moment that we did know s,
and we formed a column
vector from the bits of s, just like is shown right here.
If we were to multiply that vector by m and then take the result modulo-2, or another way of saying that
is that we replace addition
with the eXclusive OR, then we will necessarily
get the all-zero vector.
That's because each of the
entries in this resulting vector is none other than the
binary dot product of s
with one of the rows of m.
If S happens to be the all-zero string, we'll always get the zero vector from the binary dot product.
And if s is not the all-zero string, we'll get this from what we
know about the probabilities for the strings y1 through yk to appear.
In particular, the
binary dot product with s is always zero for all of these strings.
A simple way of saying that is that this vector
formed from the bits of s is always in the null
space of the matrix m,
assuming that we're doing all
of our arithmetic modulo-2, but of course, we don't know what s is,
we're trying to find s.
But what we can do is that we can compute the
null space of this matrix m, once again, modulo-2.
Specifically, we can do that using the technique of
Gaussian elimination, which is the procedure that's often taught
in introductory linear algebra courses.
It works perfectly well when we do all of our arithmetic modulo-2, and it can be done quite
efficiently with a computer.
And if we compute the null space of m, given the specific way that these k strings have
been randomly chosen,
we will be able to recover s with probability greater than
1 minus 2 to the negative r.
To be specific, what we will see with probability greater than
1 minus 2 to the negative r is that the null space
includes the all-zero vector,
as it always does for every matrix, as well as the vector corresponding to s, whether it's the all-zero vector or not.
And most importantly, no other vectors will
appear in the null space.
It's actually not too hard to prove this, although I won't go through it in detail.
The idea is that if we
have some other string that isn't the all-zero
vector and it isn't s, then each one of the random
strings, y1 through yk,
is basically going to knock
it out of the null space with probability a half.
So after k shots, it's not
at all likely to survive, and in fact, none of the
strings that don't belong
are likely to survive. And a very simple fact
from probability theory, known as the union bound, can
be used to establish that.
I haven't explained all
of the details here, but hopefully, you get the idea that by computing the null
space modulo-2 of this matrix m,
we are very likely to recover s, and that's how Simon's algorithm
solves Simon's problem.
There's just one thing left
to say about Simon's problem, and it concerns the classical
difficulty of this problem,
that is, how many queries does a classical query algorithm need to solve Simon's problem?
The answer is, a lot, in general.
There are different precise
statements that can be made about the classical
difficulty of this problem, and here's just one of them.
If we have any probabilistic
query algorithm and that algorithm makes fewer than 2 to the power n over 2
minus 1, minus 1 queries,
so that's a number of queries
that's exponential in n, then that algorithm will fail
to solve Simon's problem,
with probability at least a half.
Sometimes, proving
impossibility results like this can be very challenging, but this one isn't too difficult to prove
through an elementary
probabilistic analysis.
I won't do that in this video lesson, and I'll just instead focus
on the intuition behind it.
We're trying to find the hidden string s, but so long as we don't query the function on two strings having
the same output value,
we'll get very limited
information about s.
Basically, all we learn is
that the hidden string s is not the eXclusive OR of any two distinct
strings that we've queried,
And if we query the function at fewer than this number of queries, there will still be a lot of choices of s
that haven't been ruled out.
This isn't a formal proof,
but that is the basic idea.
So in summary, Simon's algorithm provides us with a striking advantage of quantum over classical
algorithms within the query model.
In particular, Simon's
algorithm solves Simon's problem with a number of queries that's linear in the number of input
bits n to our function,
whereas any classical algorithm,
even if it's probabilistic, needs to make a number of
queries that's exponential in n
in order to solve Simon's problem with a reasonable probability of success.
It's true that Simon's problem is a somewhat artificial problem that presumably nobody
really wants to solve,
but that's secondary. Sometimes ideas need to be developed before they're put into practice.
And indeed, Peter Shor has clearly stated that it was Simon's algorithm that inspired his now
famous quantum algorithm
for integer factorization, which we'll see in a couple of lessons.
And that is the end of Lesson 5.
In this lesson, we've taken a look at the
query model of computation, and we've seen a progression of examples
of quantum algorithms
that exhibit advantages over classical algorithms
within this model.
There is, in fact, a lot more
known about the query model and quantum algorithms for other problems that
I've not discussed.
So if you find this
model to be interesting, there's quite a lot
more to learn about it.
Our next step will be to move
away from the query model and toward a model of computation
that's more representative
of the sorts of problems that we might hope to solve in practice.
I hope you'll join me for Lesson 6, where will focus mainly on
laying down a foundation for studying quantum algorithms.
And from there, we'll move on to some
specific quantum algorithms, including Shor's algorithm
for integer factorization
in subsequent lessons. Goodbye until then!